the Xbox one had a rocky start when it
first launched in 2013
since then Microsoft has ditched the
Kinect made several software
improvements on the Xbox one s
represents the company's latest attempt
at bolstering the Xbox ecosystem with a
slimmer more capable design but in 2016
is it enough
let's find out the Xbox one s comes in
three variants there's a $300 500
gigabyte model the $350 one terabyte
model and the $400 2 terabyte model
which I'm reviewing here it doesn't come
with a Kinect but if you already have
one with the older model Microsoft says
you're eligible for a free USB adapter
otherwise it will cost you 40 bucks the
original Xbox one was bulky and frankly
looked a little bit like a VCR this
version here is 40 percent smaller and
uses a mostly white aesthetic overall it
looks clean
despite its smaller size it never got
loud or hot either
perhaps the most impressive thing here
is that Microsoft managed to squeeze the
power break into the chassis while
making it smaller
considering the Xbox one's original
power brick was massive that's a
technical marvel in my book with the
exception of the missing Kinect port the
S maintains the same ports the new
chassis also rearranges certain buttons
for instance the controller pairing
button and single USB port that used to
be located on the left of the console
have been moved to the front where they
are more easily accessible the
capacitive touch button has also been
replaced with the physical one which is
good for preventing accidental shutdowns
the system's cooling has also been
redesigned to allow you to position it
to stand vertically with the consoles
included stand inside the Xbox the main
ingredients remain largely the same it
still uses an 8 core CPU from AMD with 8
gigabytes of ddr3 RAM the GPU frequency
has received a 7 percent boost going
from 853 megahertz to 914 you likely
won't notice improved
graphical performance but the extra
performance Headroom allows the console
to support HDR and 4k video streaming
what is HDR it stands for high dynamic
range and it provides a much higher
contrast ratio between black and whites
it also displays a much wider visible
color gamut essentially like 4k it's
poised to be the next
and panel technology like 4k you'll need
a TV that supports it games will also
need to support it
Gears of War 4 and Forza horizon 3 are
examples of upcoming HDR compatible
games one disappointing aspect of the
Xbox 1s is that it still uses a slow
5400 rpm hard drive
sadly you still can't upgrade the drive
for a better speed or more storage
moving on to the controller it remains
largely the same the biggest difference
here is that it features a new textured
grip which gives it a gentle almost
sandpapery feel Microsoft also says the
bump sticks have been redesigned to
withstand more wear and tear but I
couldn't feel the difference with
Microsoft announcing that its new
project Scorpio is on the way next year
that leaves the Xbox one s in a weird
spot who exactly is this for well if you
don't already have an Xbox one and one
an HDR 4k blu-ray player then this
console is a must buy as far as I'm
concerned it's even a little cheaper
than standalone players if you already
own an Xbox one
I wouldn't upgrade unless you really
want the 4k HDR support if you've been
on the fence with the Xbox one have been
waiting for the library to mature the
Xbox 1's makes it a great time to jump
on board its slim is the only model that
can be outfitted with a 2 terabyte hard
drive is priced fairly and offers the
effort mentioned of video features if
you don't care about all that and just
want to play xbox one games I'd actually
recommend the original Xbox one over the
ass it's 500 gigabytes key retails for
$250 which is $50 less than the
comparable s model the Xbox one s might
not be a huge overhaul you'll want to
wait for project Scorpio if that's what
you seek but it is without a doubt the
sleekest most feature-rich Xbox yet